[Musique]
un peu de bulles beaucoup passionnément
mais comment choisir un appareil
l'importance de pouvoir retrouver la
quantité de bulles qu'on souhaite à
chaque fois et comment on mesure ça on
goûte voulait plus bois
notre expert frédéric chabot a testé six
appareils à gazéifier pour la qualité de
la bouteille la facilité d'utilisation
et la capacité à reproduire à chaque
fois le même niveau de gazéification
deux modèles de sodastream le source
îles fidji le drink might le fils botte
de la compagnie greenpod est le plus
cher l'appareil de 1 alors le principe
par la base est toujours le même j'ai un
cylindre avec du gaz comprimé dedans et
ça me prendre simplement une valve avec
un injecteur pour faire rentrer le gaz
de danse le sixième appareils de notre
banc d'essai est le seul qui ne se
disent pas de ds comprimé laisse par
contre lui fonctionne avec une réaction
chimique se font de poule qui sont
ménagés ensemble i qui dégage du co2 de
co2 va être incorporé dans l'eau à la
paresse par cole prend beaucoup plus de
temps pour préparer la boisson il se
fait beaucoup plus d'étapes
les écoliers sont tellement multiples
que je pense que l'avantagé aux points
serment que la chandelle les soda stream
ils sont très simples à utiliser
j'insère la bouteille dans le mécanisme
je pousse est ce juste injecté rpc et si
jamais j'ai mis trop de gaz dans la
bouteille la pression est trop élevée
une valve de sécurité qui permet à la
pression créée du gaz ici de se libérer
le source de sodastream et le spy comme
sont les seuls à posséder des
indicateurs pour le niveau de
gazéification l'appareil haut de gamme
un cas est aussi très apprécié par notre
expert mais il coûte 300 dollars ça
s'explique par la qualité de
l'assemblage des matériaux par le loup
par le désert
mais sinon le point de vue fonctionnel
c'est exactement le même mécanisme
les cylindres de co2 sont identiques
d'un appareil à l'autre donc
interchangeables mais on trouve surtout
celui de sodastream en magasin les
autres se vendent sur internet
les six appareils nous permettre de
faire des boissons gazeuses en ajoutant
des sirops ou des arômes mais le drink
mais tu es le seul de notre sélection
qui en plus de l'eau gazéifiée aussi des
jus et les alcools comme le vac nous
l'avons testé avec une gîte canneberge
ce qui est intéressant sur le dripping
c'est le seul une graduation aussi donc
si je fais le reste est un cocktail si
je vais avoir juste un petit peu de
bulles space 2 selon une j'en veux plus
je peux peut-être pesé 3.4 secondes dans
les appareils par cole et fils pod
on peut ajouter des jus et des aliments
solides avant la gazéification ces
fabricants la savante d'ailleurs que la
gazéification avec des morceaux de
fruits d'un arbre extraire davantage de
savoir que si je mangeais de l'eau avec
une fruits nous avons testé le fils
potes de deux façons en mettant les
clémentines avant et après la
gazéification
alors je goûte les expériences que j'ai
faites m'ont démontré que juste que je
le fasse à la main de façon statique
vous avec une cuillère ou que je fasse
sous pression il y en a point qu'il
goûte plus aucune goutte - ben alors
lajoux est beau mais y apporte pas plus
de savasse par contre l'installation du
sud est vraiment sain n'est pas de
panneaux en arrière et démonter ipc de
levis et par en arrière du bout des
doigts
donc ça fonctionne très bien comme pour
le drink min
l'injection se fait par le bouchon les
bouteilles sont très différentes d'un
appareil à l'autre un goulot l'âge peut
être pratique pour mettre des fruits
comme celui de facebook mais
simon avait beau pas très profonde si
j'ai pas un col de 5
ces problématiques les bouteilles peu
importe leurs différences comporte
plusieurs mises en garde ne pas
égratigner ne pas mettre au lave
vaisselle ne pas mettre à la chaleur
supérieure à 40° même pour la laver et
attention la plupart des bouteilles ont
une date de péremption sur le cylindre
de dioxyde de carbone on indique qu'on
peut densifier jusqu'à 60 litres d'eau
ou faux cloud est saturée de gaz by owdi
15 quand même puissance du cil 1 mais
qui s'empare laval
donc c'est une gare lgv qui est
gaspillée donc dans la réalité on
prendra entre 30 à 40 bouteilles par
semaine
souvent les gens choisis ces appareils
là pour réduire leur empreinte
écologique
donc c'est sûr que je peux remplir la
même bouteille plusieurs fois est ce qu
ont eu une idée de la quantité de
bouteilles qu'on peut sauver à lorient
sodastream qui se vante de pouvoir faire
économiser trois mille bouteilles par
année par familles ce qui représente
plus de huit bouteilles par jour
mais même si vous ne consommez pas
autant vous réduisez tout de même la
production de bouteilles de plastique à
savoir maintenant si vous pouvez
économiser avec les appareils vendus
autour de 120 dollars nous avons fait
ses calculs si on tient compte du coût
de l'appareil et des cylindres pour
faire par exemple 200 bouteilles par
année pendant cinq ans votre eau
gazéifiée vous reviendra à 69,7 la
bouteille plutôt qu'un dollar en moyenne
pour les eaux vendus en épicerie
alors quel appareil choisir
parce qu'on a vu la qualité de la bulle
c'est assez semblable pour tous les
appareils
ce support juste de l'eau ghazi ici
l'essor de ce film fonctionne quand même
assez bien pour faire définitivement le
source sûre que je vote problème moi ce
que je préfère c'est vraiment le rythme
malgré son mécanisme et semble comme
tout régime mais le drink me permet de
faire plus que de l'eau puis son
processus est quand même assez simple
son mode d'emploi est simple c'est
quelque chose qui fonctionne quand mr
seydoux
[Musique]